so everything that is happening around
from Barren is terrible there is the
possibility of learning something from
this though and I want to take this
opportunity because there are lots of
people in my audience who may be too
young to remember the march to war with
Iraq in March of 2003 and in 2002
leading up to the eventual invasion of
Iraq in 2003 this was one of the first
big political events in my life so we
had 9/11 in 2001 that and I remember
that and then I remember following and
sort of processing what was going on and
eventually we got to the lead-up to and
the eventual invasion of Iraq in 2003
during the George W Bush administration
one of the characteristics of the lead
up to the Iraq war was the
propagandizing about imminent threats
from Saddam Hussein Saddam was linked to
the 9/11 attacks of course that wasn't
true the reality at the time we later
found out was that the war in Iraq had
already been agreed upon in a sense it
had been pointed to as a target a decade
earlier when George HW Bush didn't get
done what he wanted to get done in Iraq
and then it was just a matter of
manufacturing enough public consent to
go ahead and do it and with 9/11 and
with : Powell and condi rice citing
bogus intelligence and saying we've got
to go it's an imminent threat it's time
to do it they were ultimately able to
manufacture enough consent to go and do
it we are seeing a very very similar
propaganda campaign now around Iran with
some key differences let's talk about
the differences number one Trump is not
george w bush without romanticizing
george w bush because he was a disaster
Donald Trump is much more unhinged than
Bush in terms of Bush at least felt the
need to fabricate a bogus case for going
into Iraq Donald Trump doesn't really
seem to feel the need to do that and you
will see that by virtue of how thin the
justification they're giving is another
important difference between Iran 2020
and Iraq 2003 is that the media today
is not what it was in 2003 Fox News was
around in 2003 I think in 96 Fox News
started but in 2003 Fox News was not
what it is now the social media echo
chambers that further manufacture
consent were nothing in 2003 compared to
what they are today so let's dig into
this the case that the White House is
making for why it made sense to without
authorization from Congress which Donald
Trump claimed when Barack Obama was
president was necessary for this type of
military action without even
communicating with congressional leaders
without even communicating with our
European allies Donald Trump says he
urgently had to go in and assassinate
Kasim soleimani because he was
imminently planning attacks against
American forces and diplomats in the
Middle East no evidence has been
presented so again difference from 2003
in 2003 they created all sorts of
evidence much of which we later found
out was incorrect in order to justify
going into Iraq Donald Trump is not even
presenting any evidence what they are
saying is oh it was just imminent it was
imminent and it all appears to be a lie
to US officials briefed about this say
that the evidence for assassinating
Kasim soleimani is quote razor thin
that's diplomatic speak for there is no
real evidence we've just created a
speculative case based on some isolated
and irrelevant facts and we know what
those facts are according to reporter
Brooke mini kalamaki the so-called
evidence was number one Soleimani z'
pattern of travel number two Salah
Manny's request to visit the Supreme
Leader of Iran to get approval for an
operation it could be anything and
number three so LeMond EES allegedly
more belligerent position towards
American interests in Iraq this is not
evidence of imminent attacks this is not
a good guy we don't at any point it's
important for the left not to feel like
we have to defend Soleimani he was a bad
guy he did horrible things the question
is by Trump's own standards of requiring
congressional approval and not being a
bloodthirsty war monger was this the
right thing to do the answer is no we
then have much like with Saddam Hussein
and
2002 in 2003 the 911 card which has been
pulled vice president Mike Pence
mentioned this tweeting that Kasim
soleimani quote assisted in the
clandestine travel to Afghanistan of ten
to twelve ten of the twelve terrorists
who carried out the September 11
terrorist attacks in the United States
this is so flaccid that you could just
blow and it would fall over like a piece
of paper remember that if assisting in
travel is evidence of complicity in 9/11
the u.s. gave the 9/11 hijackers visas
and allowed them to come to the United
States it's it's thin in both cases and
it is not actually evidence of anything
the 9/11 Commission looked at
allegations of Iran's complicity in 9/11
no Iranian --zz were involved there were
no Iranian zin the al Qaeda Network that
carried out the attack this is
revisionist history and we can't allow
it and I feel like I'm being transported
back almost 20 years to 2002 and the
lead up to the Iraq war lastly and I
hate to say lastly because this actually
is a huge deal there is still no serious
legal basis for this assassination that
has been established we will certainly
be talking more about the legal basis
and that Fiasco later on this week the
consensus from many foreign policy
analysts and simply from rational people
able to think is that this is exactly
what Trump said Obama would do but it's
Trump who's doing it Trump tweeted
endlessly years ago that Barack Obama in
order to help himself get reelected
would go to war with Iran we don't have
to look far here look at some of Donald
Trump's old tweets quote in order to get
elected Barack Obama will start a war
with Iran quote now that Obama's poll
numbers are in a tailspin watch for him
to launch a strike in Libya or Iran he
is desperate quote now that Obama's poll
numbers are in tailspin
wata I already read that one there are
many many more Obama didn't do it
Trump is impeached Trump is facing a
tough re-election it is abundantly clear
that one element here is Trump doing
this to distract from impeachment and
because he believes it will
help him get reelected in 2020 and I
hate to admit this it's really it's
disgusting that I be lying if I didn't
admit it it actually might work if you
have seen how quickly most Republican
senators and almost all trumpets have
fallen in line and said hey listen this
was a bad guy
Trump is big and strong he went and he
got him he's sending the message that
you cannot do this you cannot attack
American interests or people or assets
overseas or anywhere they are falling in
line much like many of the we will be
greeted as liberators crowd fell in line
behind the Iraq propaganda of : Powell
and Donald Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney and
of course George W Bush in 2002 in 2003
this might actually work and get Donald
Trump re-elected just ten months from
today we're going to keep talking about
this but in the meantime let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show